you gotta go out there make challenges
you know you gotta make your challenge
here go on television make challenges go
to the television show everybody scared
of me in the UFC you can't cry for your
family your mother your father your
sister your children all know your couch
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing with Mike Tyson I'm Evan
Britain and I'm Mike Tyson Mike we got a
[ __ ] everybody's gonna know your name is
are the name babies after you man be
careful man we're condoms man oh you
would a lawyer with you at all times man
that's all you need a trainer and a
lawyer you need nothing else only no
hang-ups you need not unless you got
your agent your training your lorda your
lawyer Francis and Johnny welcome my
brother and great to have you really
fresh it is a huge oh no phone now I was
just watching you before me you knocked
everybody knock I'm the solo I was
eating like that square though he'd
knocked my man from Harlan I ovary now
over arm and this is some good stuff
some really legends that some all-time
greats out man you know six years ago I
was in in Morocco trying to find my way
to go to to Europe because that that's
always been my dream to get somewhere
that I can have opportunity and out
there you know you were just like
immigrating so every we was illegal you
know like those similar like mystique
and trying to cross the border you get
job
no no job we're sometimes we deep in the
forests hiding for the cops trying to
cross the border to go to Spain and
anytime that and it was you have food no
sometimes we eat sometimes we have to go
hand sometimes we have to go way to the
trash truck anybody you and with a Haney
food never know when they come we have
to hide because we we didn't know who
was the police or not and there was like
in a real cool a close some time to come
there detectives yes and when I went in
rough sometimes you have a hard time and
we have a chance to go to sometimes you
have a chance to go on use internet on
tonight and I always watch boxing
because my dream was to boxing that was
like my motivation to wash Mike Tyson on
YouTube because that's when I never wash
or fight guys because I grew up in
Africa and I didn't have a damn TV
nothing like that you know and I was
watching it I'm like damn I cannot do
this I'm gonna do this I wash all this
fight I go through this I'm like how is
it possible to be like Haiti way because
heavyweight does support usually they
are not so technical you know that how
like how is it possible to be like
heavyweight and be so technical
everything was like like perfect you
know and even today I still believe that
I can put Mike Tyson video and then to
teach those kid books and to say okay
this how you put you raise your hand
this how you move this how you dodge
this how you do the clock because
everything even in the fight was great
which is something that I haven't seen
before that you don't see often because
when you see this professional fighter
obviously as a matter of fighter they
did all this stuff raised their hand
most perfect leap and when they become
pro everybody hand down is that and you
can show some kids like this outer box
that doesn't make sense why do you tell
me that the boss like this and the
professional boxer is boxing like these
like that you know and it was for me or
something just unbelievable and he was
my motivation because despite my
situation at the time I always believed
that
I don't know why but he seems like I had
some voice in my mind would told me that
it's going to happen how I don't know
that it's gonna happen and then I'm like
yes I'm gonna do it and I was just like
six to seven years ago and today I'm
here you're telling me about my ko which
is like where I'm like yeah no you did
what you don't know what you didn't know
what you did your um um your words were
your destiny you spoke out your reality
music imma do that that's what happened
to me I was locked up in a juvenile
detention center and what in 1978 maybe
1970 not something today is 78 77 I was
like what
twelve eleven I was locked up in a
juvenile detention and I'll be watching
the movie the greatest and it was cool
and as soon as the lights came on
Muhammad Ali came in as soon as he came
in everybody lost I mean the staff they
put the cars a but look and that was I
wanna be like him first thing I want to
be like him I don't know why I said it
maybe because they both class I'm going
crazy that one that sort of dinner and I
got high off that rushed I said I want
to be like him did I kill you know
detainees I didn't even have a chance to
have a real murder on life like
obviously we heard about my Dyson but I
couldn't watch Mike Tyson fight we
didn't have TVs you know we barely have
a lamp to read our book I start to work
at ten I was ten years old to be able to
support my scholarship and that's how I
grew up but you're right because the
teen is like you know in where I'm from
I'm from Cameroon and from some small
village and it's very people they are
very hopeless because I feel like they
lose everything nothing is made for them
you know they are forgettin and don't
like okay you have to set her to this
and that's why I always have problem
with my family because I was a dream I
was very ambitious I'm like I want this
I'm like no
you are not you enough for that glass of
life
you don't belong to that class and you
can't do it I'm like why why I can't do
it I'm like no you have to be like a
farmer like your dad you have to do this
like your grandpa I'm like then who says
who say that we say you can check he can
change you know then and I really looked
back at that time like just being
[Music]
doesn't agree with my parents with my
elder so he was like I was like a bad
seed you know a monkey that's what you
were called yeah I was a very bad one so
at the point that when I go somewhere
some if i if i sat here somebody you
just change his wallet and put on this
item like this kid is so ambitious he's
gonna end up bad you know
nobody never understand like what was my
dream I'm like I just have to change the
situation I just have to be something
else you know I believe that I can make
my own destiny
I mean nobody say one B says he won't be
he will be easy but it's still possible
you know and they're always my thought
and I think that's one of the thing that
made me decide to know to make the
change like I can do my aunt in and
basically when I came up with my dream
to become a boxer I'm like what the [ __ ]
is that would tell you is possible for
you look at you
look where you came from how is it
possible look in the entire country who
have who had succeed with the boxing
then they would take some example
they'll say like because we have some
famous boxer who unfortunately didn't do
great life wise name like Joseph Basara
jean-marie may be like what a belly
Don's mentioned those graham like look
at those guy their life their life is
miserable I'm like yes but
my own does I have to end up like that
you can be different I can't take my own
chance my own chance and doesn't matter
if I fell you know
I'm at least a try you know the the
loser is those what the guy who didn't
try if you try and didn't make it you
are not a loser you know and maybe
you're gonna do something else but be in
peace with yourself like okay I tried if
I'm a strong believer and you know yeah
during my life my life is full of
mistakes but I didn't stand on the wall
and do nothing I did something you know
I didn't know the dooba and I made a bit
of a mistake but it did something oh oh
yeah oh hey yeah you did a lot
understand on the wall and still nothing
did something and then when your song
worth fighting for dream for your dream
for something to make something and then
they came up with some story like with
Mike Tyson
on and this guy will end up go to jail
and come back and to be in the top level
on like everything is possible you know
anything I mean it's like a motivation
sometimes good things are really good
but the most important thing some time
that you can also look up in what's
supposed to be bad and see the good in
it and that's what that's what is really
important that what you learn out of it
you know I remember Ali
you know he didn't go to prison but they
took his he can fight for three years
yeah and he came back venting when the
title you know after losing the cool
losing the fridge and loads in the
Norton but he still came back and won
the title that's because he refused to
go to Vietnam oh absolutely yeah and
when I want the prison for three that's
imma do it too just like are lame but I
won the title the first fight he didn't
won the first fight we're afraid that's
the first fight of a win yeah I think
it's always good when you have to look
to I mean you human we are weak and we
always need to look up to somebody as an
example or ours yes
same things myself you know I said when
I thought ugly and I didn't really never
I didn't see I live in this crime by
sorry Linda and I ran and I and soon as
I saw them I said I this is what I'm
gonna do with my life I'll die before I
not make this swim dedicate my life to
those guys and some guys followed in the
people and created some what the people
to do that for me for me it's for [ __ ]
me up me up me out it watching him fight
as [ __ ] I won't do that I want to be
those guys you know it's pretty cool
Mike that you had that experience and
then through your career you can inspire
guys like Francis you know a thousand of
thousands of gang of corn is of course
because I believe inspiration is not
just about you you inspire people not
just in boxing but in everything some
guy who maybe has struggle as a lawyer
or journalist or whatever or
entrepreneur he might listen to your
story worship look out to you and then
you know be inspired by and there's a
lot of people out there like this just
like when you talk about those guys you
keep your hands up nobody keep your
hands up because if you don't keep your
hands up look what happened to the guy
she knocked out didn't keep their hands
I mean so happened keep your hands up
and that is life in general because gods
up and I feel God the country scarred it
up in life yeah I didn't have
opportunity to do boxing on T I was 22
that was the first time I worked with a
boxing gym I was 22 years old how did
you get there very interesting because
you know I was a you know this
motorcycle taxi in Africa I was doing it
Wow yes and at some point I'm like so I
can do this all my life
and how about my dream
I'm like you know and this I've been
working on this being working in my mind
for a very long time and that's a 22 I'm
like okay I'm done because I left school
I was 17 so he was five years after I'm
like he'd been five years
what did i do exactly nothing
I'm like I'm gonna chase my dream then I
saw that motorcycle
oh my family everybody said this guy
lost his mind piece
her friends his friends his brain crazy
his hips or his bike to the thoughts
what is boxing what the hell is boxing
I'm like I don't know exactly what the
hell is perceiving that is I know what
is my dream and I gonna try it I don't
have there's no guarantee that are gonna
succeed I mean to be honest there was no
guarantee there was not even I can't
even I can't even blame them to don't
believe in me because they was just
realistic you know and but I was so
bummed out that I cannot do this then I
saw the bag I'm like I don't care about
it let's go do it I'm like you should
keep doing your job find a wife do this
I'm like so unhappy it and they have the
same miserable life ask me being ashamed
in front of the eye friend all the time
no we are gonna try something different
and that's how I worked at the boxing I
was 22 years old and what I found was a
boxing gym by you near close to where
you lived
no I must not often a grass on a good
like a ring on the ground and the dirt
is something no that's why I saw my back
because green up I have a dream to
become a my martial artist since when I
was a kid I never lost be nice so you
soccer fans I soaky's famous in my
country but never had a chance to having
some way to train in karate
in 1900 miles away around there were not
in while to train you you know so I grew
up with this i grew up with this
frustration and I was always expecting
somebody to come there and do something
you know I don't know whoa
but you know just come there and do
something who could allowed me to be
able to train yeah and then I thought
about my back and when I worked the gym
I find out some how interesting is
boxing you know it's not just about
fight it's not just about good and
knocking people out but it's about to
know how to fall for down-stay unlocking
you know fighting from thinking well
it's not for tough people they shouldn't
be fighters yeah tough people shouldn't
be fights only smart people should be
fighting because there's a thinking game
it's not a tough Man game yeah so you
first time you ever boxed 22 No yes 22 I
was ready to because when you what made
you think that you wanted to be in the
UFC who did you see fight in the UFC
so to be honest I never I didn't know
USC at the time I didn't know what was
UFC I mean I have what you saw you see a
few time on TV but I didn't even have TV
maybe see sat in some bar and so see we
have see fight and I was like okay I
don't know what is that but let's move
on until I went in France like in 2013
that was my first time then I walked to
the gym I would I didn't I was homeless
at the time because I didn't have nobody
no money I just came out to Morocco that
I've been there for 1 years then I'm
gonna treat you nice in Morocco
Oh [ __ ] it's hard to be black in
the world
not only that you're black but you're
poor you're dead you like miserable you
know you don't even have clothes you
don't have what to eat now like shitty
smell like [ __ ] sometimes you don't you
you can do like two weeks with two weeks
without take it take a shower and order
steam so oh no you see is a really
mental game this you have to be strong
in your mind the poorest section in
America is the heaven to somebody from
Africa huh yes I know and that's exactly
what's happened when I went in friends
section in America is heaven is heaven
to Africans having the poorest
[ __ ] get staying in LA the ports
are homeless all downtown a little
homeless ad in off the street that's
heaven to him as heaven that's exactly
what's happened when I went in friends
because when I went in France I couldn't
even get them the [ __ ] out what are
these people doing it I don't even have
to work I'm eating everyday you know
imagine if I start begging I might
become a millionaire man you got to sign
out there and the next thing you know
somebody a rose would come pick you up
at the end of the day and take you home
yes when I went in France it was very
interesting to see people complaining
about everything you know her was free
you can find peaceful to eat for free
and for me this was heaven
I'm like I was a homeless at the time
but I think that this was the one of the
best moment in my life I was somewhere
that I can't even I cannot care about
being sick or what to eat for the first
time in my life I was over 26 or 27 at
the time these were the very first time
and I was very happy with that even
though I was homeless and people was
like where your situation is like really
bad sorry I'm like don't don't mind me
I'm good I'm really good
no [ __ ] Amerika Amerika start getting
mad I'm gonna fool ecosystem that's the
[ __ ] guy eat the food we stop
fighting am I gonna be hungry start
stealing and taking stuff right that's
what we do when we get on we start
taking the stealing stuff robbing
stealing yeah that's how I I mean when
in France then I walk to the team and I
tell them right away I was honest with
them I'm like look guys I really want to
do this but I don't have no money even
no clothes nothing no place to sleep but
I just want somewhere that I can train
because I can I know when I saw you yeah
yeah yeah so it was kind of like to
controvert sorting like this guy worked
at rue the gym with nothing and just
like it's gonna be war champion so we
are here we don't want to be world
champion you know so it's this kind of
ego but at the meantime they looked at
man and I'm like okay let's give him
some credit you know yeah and I'm like
okay we're gonna talk to the man coach
and see what he said and four day after
they caught me and say yes the coach
agree that you can't train you can come
train with us and I was very happy I was
like this is the beginning of every Wow
how old were you then 2,200 no 827 he
said yes I was in France that's why this
is what thousand thirteen mmm
I believe it doesn't matter of anybody
determination of world is what counts
you know maybe we have to you know I
mean the tenacity the resilience you
know I'm a determination the willpower
to succeed doesn't matter what age you
are have to have yeah yes it was it if
mindset how we polled is positive had
manly manly affectionate in love with
yourself you have to love yourself to
treat yourself right there's no way you
gonna be successful you don't have me
not madly in love with yourself you have
to believe you deserve all the success
that you you're being given you know I
mean success you know myself I'm the
oldest money hundreds of me I don't
deserve this I got it too easy and then
work really hard to get
really I'm hanging out and I'm partying
I'm beating these guys leading one to
round and I thought my mind started
playing games got negative with me
started getting self-destructive you
know the fall you always think about
beautiful things what are you gonna do
that how am I set my children up for the
future always have goals I want you to
once I accomplish that goal the youngest
chairman or whatever it was it got
tricky then I'm gonna take more time off
to spend time here do this now I come to
my goal one I want to stop me and girl
won't stop meeting new people and what's
up learning things you forget your zest
a focus to us over the fat ladies things
you know when you when people watch you
sometimes fighters are watching you
other fighters are watch and see if
you're stripping if you didn't know
people that hang around you was he doing
how's he working out you know we're
waiting for you to fall you're
threatening to people
yes that's Nikki our own yeah and she
doing yeah a stay on top always stay
pods let them see you working hard at
all times always prepared
that's what fighting is about always
being prepared never know when that
championship fights will come a guy Mike
fall out say you got you ready
championship mask I'd be ready at all
times
mmm-hmm so be at dinner someone with
fight call you ready to fight all times
be ready when was your first pro fight
he was four months after we started I
started Wow yes I mean I was dead my
very first time I was 27 and I went to
the gym I'm like started do boxing I'm
them like okay so if you need the faster
and come to help you get out in your
situation you have to do MMA then I'm
like what's MMA I'm like this mix masher
oh okay that's good but what's mixed
martial art what does that mean you know
so I have to tell them or they have to
explain me all those things then I'm
like no man I don't want to do that [ __ ]
I just want to do
boxing you know the Mike Tyson boxing
they say yes all night
let's do that one that's what I've been
looking for
I don't want a wrestler I don't want to
do all these things I'm like okay but
keep that in mind you know but teen put
him together like humans after I went to
the gym was a cross fight MMA factory
and they say the same thing like yes
you should do MMA and there was like
specialized in MMA and I'm like okay
since I just have my time let's do it
I was doing Burks in an MMA and was one
more than half someone after they said
yes we have a fight we think we should
you should try him like really they say
yeah like okay let's go for it that turn
now the first one was good the second
one I lost the second one and I think
that's why I keep doing MMA B was the
second one I was about to win that fight
win the title I'm like cookie I'm done
with the MMA experience let's go to the
boxing but I lost the fight since I
couldn't leave the MMA with on with the
loss so you sound like I'm quitting
I'm like no that's not a good idea I
can't do that I have to clean this out
then that's how I keep move yeah and
then then the next one I get paid like
two thousand-year-old yes he was a
tournament 2000 year oh wow that was the
first money in Europe I just call in
Africa I'm like a mom you know do you
still have have you celebrate this
because in March 8th is like
international women day I say how was
your an international women day from
like well you know I'm like you know
what you can have a special
international women day your son is out
here take you were just too so yeah you
were just 2,000 year old but oh because
you use a lot of
you know a lot the very first one I know
bang me yes that's awesome I never have
that money in my life that kind of money
in my life and I my friend who I was
with friends out there in France and
they always take me out and support
everybody pay my own I'm like hey guy I
got you this time it's my turn let's do
it as I did yeah that's amazing that's
beautiful
how did how did it feel then as you
you're starting to live your dream now
how did that feel were you just like
this is it this is where I'm supposed to
be you know I mean I love what I'm doing
I love where I am but I think I haven't
achieved my dream mmm
I'm doing great my life has to change
what is he some bad mmm
what are you doing my dream my mind
mentoring is today to become a boxer and
I think yeah I would take that dream
away stay in the line I still have that
dream in the line and I believe that I
can achieve it you know yeah because
what have five boxes matches yeah yes
what's happened before with the UFC I
was just there so when I I want the
stone mint and I get this money and then
I'm like very excited so at least I get
something I get paid for something
because I didn't have paper in residence
card and I couldn't even work you know
so there is something that I can have
money out of it I'm like okay let's do
it maybe to have money then two years
after like it was my birthday my
birthday
and my coach called me I'm like guess
what I'm like I don't know tell me he
was like yes we just got your us a
contract I'm like really
and what did that mean exactly because I
didn't even like expecting or dreaming
too much about UFC I'm jobs like where
whatever but I want to become a boxer
that was my dream then since the UFC was
the opportunity right there who came to
me I had to take it before figure out
what next but how to take the
opportunity you know so that's how I get
in the USA biggest purse you ever had
yet my bigger purse yeah well it's not
millions like yours expect that yeah
you're gonna get your day trust half of
me now that's a lot coming back home
from Africa yeah it'll be more trust me
yes a deposit so life is all about
attitude oh yes give a wonderful
attitude yeah yeah and what I like in it
is like I mean I can't say I have
achieved maybe some part of my dream not
all of them but some part of it because
when I go back home today I look at my
family you know I'm I'm happy I'm happy
that they are not concerned about
anything anymore you know because my
biggest fear before I left him alone I
went see my see my mom I I stayed with
my mom for like three weeks she didn't
know why I was there for that long but I
was there because that was my last time
before I leave and I didn't know how
it's going to turn and I'll end up out
there because people die you're going in
the ocean with note with the life
preserver
here and you don't know what's gonna
happen then I'm like looking at staring
on my mom sometime like did and shows
like what I'm like no nothing so I was
thinking like maybe this might be the
last time that aunt I'm seeing her or
but I have to do this otherwise you know
how do I can exchange the situation
because we've been through a lot and our
mom always been there for us and I'm
like okay this has to change sometime
you know as a kid I I was able to see
the fear in the eye of my mom I'm like
she doesn't have to to fear she doesn't
have to be like that
and one of my goal was to take that fear
out of her and it took a long time to
make her feel like safe it was like when
I started to do my team and like send
money to her and she was even scared to
use the money because some like okay if
I use it today tomorrow what's gonna
happen tomorrow you know when you when
you don't have for a long time you have
something you try and extend it for all
the rest of the time I'm like mom I got
you let's do it like you know but it
been a long process trial process to get
her over here in America I tried I tried
to make her come to my last fight but
they denied her visa for twice I tried
twice you know but I'm gonna try again
next year okay well when the US are
gonna go in France first we're gonna
make that happen in France agent
cipriano something like that it hurt me
but this it's not a it's not just about
my agent my egos I'm talk about Louis
you know it's political stuff we are a
small country coming to America who are
you what is your position in life you
know my star is a star fighter in an
American and UFC organization no and his
name is certain shot and this is his
name and he's Jeremy to be champion yeah
that we represent in this country yeah
that's cool but he doesn't help us much
because even the UFC helpful you know
they write the write down the letter and
everything perfect but support
everything I needed and work
you have did he ever get you any
immigration lawyers with an integration
we're gonna try that next time but the
first time we taught these gun shows
gonna be I get some bad Gration lawyers
she gonna come here man is not no way
that she gonna come here that's gonna do
or dream you know do you juggle for your
family to do so much for your families
yeah it's amazing that you could do that
you gonna take care of your family that
way what is your next fight I think you
should ask Dina why that Christian he's
the boss you know what I don't know I
don't have the answer with that creature
not asking myself you can't listen
she'll forget still yeah stay in shape
that the people keep you got Alex at the
Publix keep your face in and perspective
let people know yeah yeah great personal
time Africans come over there like the
smile a lot and happy like you they
[ __ ] put them in front of everything
yes and I really see that loopy girl the
girl the black Africa you know I'm told
they got her everywhere she's like an
actress yeah Lupita yes young go yeah
she's like everywhere she's like the
honorary white person and stuff she goes
placing African Americans don't go you
know and that could be you dude
and then you open the door for other
Africans that's the matter I should
purpose you ask me you know that way
yeah yeah I believe that you know so I
was talking about like dreaming about
somebody who could when I was kid
dreaming about somebody who could come
there and do something for us and
unfortunately that person never never
came and at some point I think it was
like three years or four years ago and
I'm like because you know when you grow
up I don't know if you have that feeling
but I always have this feeling of my
childhood missing like there's something
that I still have to filled up in my
childhood box you know and I'm like okay
I gonna beat the guy me
for other kids but for myself and then I
just open a gym there a foundation for
kids you know trying to try to give them
because they might have some kids there
some kids with the same dream as me
definitely I I believe that knowing that
what that would represent for me you
know I believe that even like doing it
for like three four kids that's worth it
definitely man
so we going back is it why does why does
Dana White do [ __ ] like that like why is
it personal does he get
does he just decide does he have you
know is he judge jury and executioner
when it comes to who's fighting and who
did not know I don't think you called
Dana like a promoter pretty much right
so this is are permitted to promoter
looks who's gonna be the biggest joy of
your champion who's gonna put more
people in the seats you know you could
be listening some guy you look at a guy
like Cormier he's a great fighter right
but he's really good he's a great
fighter
this happens in boxing too great fighter
can't nobody be them but he can't bring
people to the seats like that I mean
then you get a guy that's not as
exciting than him and stuff of something
but he has this little marker he does
this thing he brings his flag in and
stuff and that excites the people you
know me they're um
what do you call what you call that
stuff when you patriotic with them and
all that stuff this is the really
patriotic country especially when you
bring the flag in the ring but I feel
like Francis is a guy that people are
excited to see fight I think so too
I don't know if Dana thinks oh no I
think right now they're having a
issue having fight for me basically with
the trial og between us TP and DC
because I should be next on the title
line but since they want to do steeping
on DC that complicate everything one put
them on who are those guys sleep a mule
Church I got a call me a the idea for me
here so that's what is making my
situation complicated right now
I didn't want to fight you because I
should parked I should be fighting a
steep in X but they want to do is DP
undies we're the big heavyweights right
now steep a Cormier John Jones steam is
the charge on jump in the chair
yes I'm John John his light heavyweight
yeah you wanna fight I want to fight the
champ and I have a heavy on done
business with Stevie you know I fought
it once and that fight didn't go well
for me and I want to fix it right now
yeah I want a revenge on how the men
time I want the title this is back this
was their last fight in August he can't
I can't believe he did that come yay he
was getting beat up by teachers finally
he is bought the body shot and then as
soon as he started with that body shot
the good one come you just start to feel
really bad yeah when is there because
John Jones keeps calling out where's
John Jones in the order of that no John
John is the charm delighted away yeah he
was becoming everywhere well let let be
so I'm in the heavyweight so yeah I mean
if you come to the heavy where right now
at this hour have some fights on
back I see so they're getting ready to
promote the 35 yes with DC and mule
church and that's what really
complicated my situation you gotta go
out there and make challenges you know
you gotta make your challenge here going
television make challenges yeah go to
the television show it's a television
show the why I might not fight you know
you should go everybody should go
everybody's scared of me in the UFC you
know maybe if you're not you can't pray
for your family if mother your father
your sister your children all know
you're a coward show your family some
pride put pride in your family's name
you coward family you're a coward think
about your family this is what you think
that means I can have your wife this is
my family now you owe my family now see
you're a kind man so that's why I'm a
kind but I did it to get in their heads
yeah you know what I think I like I've
been thinking this but he would be great
if when I make my box interview I want
you in my corner I want that damn I must
you know work I'm gonna see you work -
yeah I want to get your work everything
you know on you know your life you know
you are like your library all about what
habits you have a working everyday you
go to your routine every day regardless
of sit-ups or push-ups you're running
your exercise you spawn every day you're
a hot water you're cold the vitamins you
die it's every day just every day for
like what 90 days it's every day get
what you do your Sunday off
yeah is every day every day so are you
under contract with the UFC we fight
yeah
so you have three more fights yeah that
mangalyam type of they're gonna hold you
know but his objective is to stay active
yeah I know what you know what because
she was like he was get my sparring
partners and we were just having maybe
tops wanting to be contended and we
fight for real in the gym Swamper but
his fights really pay him like a victory
you know for my paper fight for really
has to constantly keep you sharp sure
before every day fighting top guys every
day in the gym so there is training but
it's like fighting - yeah yes but my
problem now is not really being in
contract with the VSA it's just to have
fight you know because it'd been four
months already and this i standed maybe
like two month notice so it's going from
now if I have to
they're gonna offer me a fight it's
gonna be for two months we're gonna be
like six months from my last fight and I
still don't have fight so this can't
keep next 15 fights in one year you have
to stay busy it's not just past a 15-5
one year 15 fight Wow hey baby huh my
first year 80 85 84 85 my first year Wow
15 fight 15 fights in a year Wow keep it
baby stay fighting Stace you gotta be
your life you could do it reasons like
sleeping yes but you know in MMA is not
exactly like person you cannot have as
much fun dad not because there's a lot
of injury in MMA as training us in five
man listen you know let me tell you
there's some talk let me tell you you
just like our you saw the way you fight
the way I fight it moves like the
earrings you
have you ain't gonna get hurt you ain't
gonna be the one getting hurt you hurt
everybody else the percentage is just
it's that way the way you beating these
guys these guys are intimidated they
lost before you even hit them they don't
want to be in there yeah different see
when the fighters are scared to death
some guys you hit you know you don't
have them cut you feel like you're
missing this they think you're fighting
I take it serious they be playing that
but when your knee across from I gotta
take it figure I don't wanna shake your
hand to the fights over [ __ ]
don't come up and be no gentleman friend
we're gonna fight I'll shake and when
the fight is over yeah you know people
know in the crowd you know you're
serious real fight you know no you not
tap you know I'm gonna be absolute at
but I love your buddy with you you'll be
friendly when I went yeah would be
friendly they get in your head anytime
be friendly to put your guard down them
in the bell ring they questions actually
gonna [ __ ] kill you
that's what they want yeah they come at
you like a [ __ ]
it's a good brother you know we going
man then they come into the key eat your
[ __ ] dude raped his sister something
he's gonna kill yes they look like this
trade all day they keep their knife
behind can they come - he - who view
like a my brother hobby knife fight you
so hard - I know those kind of guys hey
Mike did you see that show him I can you
pass me that like different of your
buddy put your guard down it's a father
trying to kill you totally definitely do
the prereqs yeah I don't like those kind
of fight yeah but I think some guys just
able to be like to make everything to
separate everything be professional like
a fighter and just be a different guy
outside of funny you know there can be
nice maybe some to make you put your gut
gut down and someone is just nice but
when they get into there
they just have to do what they are there
for salutely
listen now that that's why boxing so
just um interesting because not
everybody could do that everybody wants
to be able to do but not everybody could
do it some guys listen I don't know you
seen this yet something fight some guys
in the gym
there could be anybody in the world a
champ it could be anybody but you put
him in a ring yeah
you guess you put some lights on you get
some popcorn a drink and say go and he
panics yeah yeah and the gym he'll kill
the champ nobody could beat them in a
gym so they get in the ring [ __ ] path
yeah hey listen some judgment gamers yes
they could do it in the gym but they
can't do they ain't ready for the big
time it's just that this is the big time
baby yeah that's big time don't care how
good you need this heart in that gut
skills really don't matter at the big
time how much good how much how much you
willing to take win that belt mmm that's
different than the other being there
yeah yeah yeah
you see that football yeah but you can
take it you know how much you can give
up how much you can take
yeah or do they get something out yeah
yeah well Francis what what are you
doing in the meantime brother what are
you doing to keep yourself sharp you
getting into movies Mike was saying
earlier
give me a movie listen man Fast and the
Furious 11 dude you're the [ __ ]
villain
[ __ ] he's a doll he's like either
action doll look at him he's cut like
the action of superhero dude definitely
that guy over there is his job so you
have to tell him he's my manager
watch out marquel come on kill me what's
your patient in this business at the age
so he's a guy come on in bro
Hey yeah whoo
named Buffett Markel Martin agent at CAA
sports
I represent the combat sports division
all right so so yeah to your point you
know Francis was he just been finished
shooting last month fast and furious and
I mean working on another big movie he
just auditioned for I can't really give
you guys he's working oh yeah yeah
that's our job
Alex Avon CAA you know I mean he can't
he chose us because we're the best in
the business were the best in the world
at what we do you know I mean you guys
gotta make them feel beautiful you know
you foreign language I'm not seeing
beautiful I'm hungry you know you know I
want it I want everything you know
everything up and still look beautiful
you still eat I do like the action
figured although yeah I haven't we
haven't thought about that the next
thing on Africa you know what I mean
yeah action figure kungfu grip MMA goes
out and say this is what I want to
accomplish
yeah I write them down said this is what
I want to do I want everybody in this
country to know my name I want to date
the most beautiful girls in town that
exactly what was beautiful scar when I
have the most nice to the most beautiful
house in Beverly Hills when people come
visit me ask my open the door that's
what I did always drip my life my big
mansion oh yeah here and I wanna fly
just envisioned it all live by the
Hershey's and [ __ ] about my next-door
neighbor with mom Malcolm Forbes I was
chill needs to come by my house and
shower here that Lamborghini g-man said
what the [ __ ] is that I first I remember
what the [ __ ] you dad like twenty it was
a beautiful G basement and I bought one
for Malcolm Forbes came out and
supported believe me I have to do is
dream to dream it your realities in your
mouth
you know you whatever you say you know
yeah they come no no ohh laughter but I
found that I realized that I got old all
that stuff Justin
Open Sesame advocate that but those are
things those are those affirmation
ancient affirmations yeah I found that
those are internet formation abracadabra
says Open Sesame and all that stuff to
the Farman ancient ancient thousands of
year old affirmations yeah speaking
boxing into his existence
you know the moment Francis and I met
that's was one of the first thing that
he said he wanted to do was not only be
become UFC champion of the world boxing
UFC gym you might not never be done
about what everybody do that would be so
awesome you know of Tyson Fury just said
you wanna cross over and come to the UFC
I'm like I'm gonna we're gonna welcome
you here and I gonna meet you give you
the return you the service in the ring
yes I [ __ ] won that Tyson Fury and
fight Tyson here - yeah I want that
fight exactly so so I'm gonna tell you
right here what was gonna happen where
I'm from I'm from San Bernardino Inland
Empire yeah so I'm so a little bit of
quick background on me I moved to Las
Vegas I'm a football player my moves
lost I worked for Dana I worked at UFC
for five years before I started repping
fighters Dana bought me my very first
suit I mean I love the guy great great
guy you have to you know he's a savage
on the business side of it but I get
that you know what I mean but now that
I'm on this side you know it's my job
and our job to make sure that fighters
like Francis has the best opportunities
to be more than just a fighter you know
what I mean what he's trying to do in
Africa for the kids that's big you know
he's got his foundation you know what I
mean he has he has dreams because again
it's prize fighting at the end of the
day you know you know a lot a lot of
times he's got to capitalize on his
talents while he's young while he's on
the top of the game so let me tell you
something listen
what he what he what he's talking about
he talked to him exists he didn't know
it you know yeah yeah I could parse it
now you know your sees one in the boxing
ring a possibility I'm gonna be involved
as well as possibility and I was saying
you don't have to go no way it's right
here no I mean we don't have to better
how about you've done oh no no no but
you don't got to go out of any way you
right here you right place saying you
see in the box I'm coming - yes that's
what I'm saying it's coming to you but
Mike it's got to be under the right
circumstances he understand the space
that the pace killing boxing is
different than UFC and that and that's
where I think you know what's gonna be
in you understand I don't know is he
willing hey I don't know about that you
know Dana smart he does he does yeah you
know Dana smart but his value you have
steered the most is rising sport in the
world
exactly but their champion don't get
paid more than the heavyweight champion
Oh Canelo just made 35 million yeah no
one watched and they were waiting on
though the UFC fight to finish yeah I
was it you know I mean right exactly no
nobody really cares I'm a much respect
to Canelo but if Dana and Zuffa boxing
whatever if they really wanted to put
the marketing dollars and promotional
dollars behind Frances who I'll ask you
who's the most marketable potential UFC
fighter to crossover in the boxing I'm
the little brother what's his name I'm
proper 12 Connor Connor Connor I I think
that's more of a spectacle I I don't
disagree he's a star yeah listen a
spectacle but listen this is where it's
not a spectacle mm-hmm
this is the only respect to get but this
is where it's not this is why that was
listen um he never I really had a boxing
match in his life Frank right he didn't
have a boxing match right he went ten
rounds with the greatest fighter in the
last hundred years of boxing
no Connor booth no you're not listening
to me you don't understand what I'm
saying
yeah he went ten rounds scored punches
on the greatest fighter in the last
twenty a hundred years did he do them
did he accomplish something star see
people look at people yes they wanna see
the black guy beat the white ones here
but look what he had to fight against
and look what he did when he fought
against it that's true because nobody
listened mad [ __ ] I never had a boxing
match neither will any fighting boxing
with me he's fighting me and we're
fighting I don't think he makes it turn
round man if he didn't we're fighting
I'm doing my thing
that's a bad [ __ ] first fight 10
rounds with the champ the best champion
elasticity is something like that that's
the winner of the fight that's the one
of this should have been a 1 round 2
round fight fight for sure they took it
easy should have been easy he had to
sweat that the fighter he was fighting
for my toes throwing back and he was
worried that's the only thing when the
guys throw him back you gotta be
apprehensive that's the only damn boxing
he's throwing back normally guys that he
should have panicking up and throwing
punches back if we kept fighting he
should have panicked he never been in
this shitty one day with the greatest
fighter in the business he should have
panicked he kept his cool so why is the
money so different if UFC has become the
fastest-growing sport in the world and
boxing is sort of on a decline hey
listen um
they is know how to promote it it's
about promoting it at the boxing 200
years and there's no what it is is habit
- we're addicted to the promotion what
does it call again I'm it's called
subliminal subliminally don't want it
buddy makes us buy it anyway we don't we
don't like him but we still buy it's fun
it's not exciting but we still buy it
right I mean because this linden time is
the right thing to do people are talking
about it cuz it's hitting everybody
people are talking about it cuz
I'm doing the boom hit you when your
friend your wife hey you think you want
to go to fight yeah we had to fight
that's what it's not like people want to
go to the fight we get forth to go to
the fight we're safe to the subliminal
message they've been doing this for
thousands of the years they know how to
they know how to make us spend our money
we're puppets just like we have people
that are puppets to us there's people
that we're puppets to you know like I
was told much my mines mines my wife
that we watch it and through wasn't this
any different watching all the
characters that's a baby and I guess
who's watching us you know someone's
watching us just like me watching those
ants you can't believe we're the
superpower we're only one here I'm
praying and I thought even tells us that
that someone's watching us we even
feeling I'm lying somebody's watching
you don't even know why we feel that we
would be feel like somebody's watching
us yeah you know but yeah to your point
I mean it is it is a habit of you know
your question was why hasn't why is
there a difference in money making
between the UFC and boxing boxing has
that tradition of paying the the
fighters 80% you know 10,000 owes money
on Friday a real fighter you know
fighting big fights what right but it's
different in the UFC but you see the UFC
fighters now they have a platform to
where I mean even Jorge miles but all he
may he made some money but now he's
calling out Canelo why because if you
cross over into that sport
your your values higher your values
increase and then you can you can kind
of demand more of that money listen
that's true too but listen I'm gonna
take it to another level
did you just you don't know about boxing
right oh this is gonna blow your mind so
thank you make that crossover now right
in that fight so you did great
he did great but it didn't turn out well
for you and you got a big payday
100 million out they say hey listen I'm
giving a fight a big [ __ ] you
feet and another hundred men I'd be off
I can't get home it didn't know what
happened gotta wake him he gets her he
gets a a [ __ ] power drink commercial
he got forty million dollars he's not a
man if he's drinking so less maybe 50 at
one but whatever he got that is just
popping this showing his [ __ ] muscle
pumping I'm not trying to make you laugh
and they love that all those
international Germans and everything
that's bigger that's why all the German
all the German and European too they
some of the all go to Africa to get palm
bones out and stuff you see a lot of
Germans and stuff coming down soon
they'll come in car camera yeah they do
that they come and stir them out and I
mean maybe is looking at him
fantasies France more antenna
thank you think I'm what do they do the
Anthony Joshua and you what those
Caucasian over there do to him you think
I'm not playing this is real [ __ ] [ __ ]
he'd be a guard I didn't even know why
they like me as know that I supposed to
like instead something it's just that
you know it's just that day one stay 50
miles you're taking once I said my mind
I'll leave living it around once I'm
with them all the way anything is so I'm
buying even though there's no good for
me it's just my mind is planted that way
yeah I want to be connected to them that
makes me feel better it makes me look
better that means my ego feels better
it's just what it is you know I know him
yes my man what's up this [ __ ] makes us
feel good know people I don't know it's
just that's how we program that's why
you're aiding you want to help famous
people you want to know the felt of
helping these people and some other
people come to you that's who we are as
people the social animals I thought
that's how do we get for bloomin a trick
to do things because it with social
animals this is the right thing we're
supposed to do but just that now we're
paying for it yeah I got a question for
you
so I mean no one can know I known in
this room knows a fighter's mind like
you do so if you're Francis what is his
next steps what do you think well listen
he always but he always he's always a
gentleman there he is right
he's always a gentleman but he could
politely call people out yes you have to
let the people know that this is what
I'm aware make them aware of what's
going on since these guys don't want to
fight it and then people make the crowds
make the people aware that the people
are afraid to fight yeah I've offered
this for him I offer this I ask him to
fight me here what does that happen to I
have to take cut off my arms to fight me
yes I'm correct like that wouldn't they
have to do from the fight because nobody
wants to listen I give you the divine
share the purse please fight me please
fight me comfort you're gonna have to
use this for hospital bill anyway please
fight use it to buy fight wheelchair
that's all please always be polite or
bitching for people want to get savage
animal even that's what they want but
they know in his they know from his past
that's what he is yeah so he doesn't
have to act like one
they know he's one so be a contrary to
be a gentleman call them up politely and
say hey listen what do I have to do to
fight you you know I'm gonna have to be
to be a little brother or something yeah
come on make your family give some prize
to your family at least you fought you
didn't stand on the wall and did nothing
to look like a coward please I'm
embarrassed asking you to fight me yeah
I'm embarrassed for you you know stuff
like this it's especially if a boxer
right won't fight an MMA guy in boxing
because I feel I want Francis to fight a
guy like Tyson I want him to fight a guy
like Dante Walter why not oh absolutely
well once you get to cut listen this
would have come down to the quick it's
easy for you to receive could you you
have it ego you have to believe in
yourself you know you have to believe
that you're here for a purpose to enrich
the world no you have to believe this
deep that fun this is where I'm born
this is where you're crossing me this
way you're crossing why do you think you
here you think you hit by osmosis this
is just you're lucky and this is the
break that you gather your life in you
and me of course if that's what you want
that's what you wanted right
oh oh yeah and that's what happened and
it's the same thing with the
championship the same thing it's like
this window jamb it comes to you your
destiny is in your mouth
and your mind and the person who once
you once you receive that that level of
confidence you know I mean and it's
practice properly
it was the pastor genius there's nothing
more supremely confident confidence
breeds success and success breeds
confidence applied properly you're in
conquerable you know it's very deep what
what you're saying because like I don't
used to talk too much to share my
thought with people because they always
think I'm like over over deke stop right
there stop right there yeah that's what
they want you to say they don't want you
to talk about yourself they want you
believed your dumb [ __ ] from Africa and
your monkey they want you to believe
that they don't want you to believe that
you Hey they don't want you to believe
that you're divinely guided they don't
want you to believe that once you
believe that the Nephilim and whether it
be these people people don't like no no
no no I don't like that that's not true
listen they love it they just don't got
the balls to be that way yeah they wish
they were you but that's why they say
that's not nice because that's what they
were this that's what they were they
were limited to so they want you to be
limited but there's nothing personal
they just want you to be in that
situation
yeah we love company that's successful
but yes they're feeling successful
successful at the ceiling you want to
break through the silver and go to the
stars the universe the galaxies yes and
I think you I don't understand I mean I
really is very interesting how the way
that you break down things because that
I can't relate in in that like if you
keep your toes to yourself when people
know your cousin how you feel about
yourself they trying to block them yeah
so you don't let them know your thoughts
never let no one know you taught you
keep your thoughts to yourself yeah
don't let nobody invade your privacy
very it's very interesting
I'm deep you have to believe this you
have to know this one thing I'm gonna
tell you this is spiritual right yeah
see your your fight feel your fights and
stuff on your nachos is spectacular know
what that means all this good stuff
happening to you know what that means
that you're favored by God you know that
right yeah right but that's not what's
something that you may not know to when
you're favored by God
you're also favored by the devil he's
coming for you too so you gotta be
strong
stay on the right side whose side you
got going on he's gonna give you power
too he's gonna get in your head too but
your suicide you don't stay with you
stay with who brought you here
hmm you stay with you go home with the
guy that brought you to the dance
you know powerfully he wants you to come
in as you go tell you either he's gonna
tell you how beautiful your [ __ ] tell
you I made you beautiful you do what I
say I'm not gonna let you get all this
fame I'm not gonna enjoy this pleasure
either he might want you to [ __ ] mind
I suppose the [ __ ] but I wanna fire you
know they get in your head you believe
you deserve it why don't you Mike Tyson
tell you know should be a foreign
language oh they talk to you like
they're your best friend you have to be
disciplined discipline is doing what you
hate to do but do it like you love it
they may be I'm gonna go home that night
remember Carl loves you so that's he
he's after you too
it's a war yeah I really believe that
you don't believe it you find out and
you have to be smart to keep to stay in
the right side
need faith because you're not smarter
than Satan brother I know you may think
smartest thing we faked me face but he's
good he knows your weakness he knows you
before you at the christening
he knew your mother before you knew your
father he knew he knows you before God
in existence they knew you together they
would even they made you together you
know you you can't no secret from you
can't talk flick the he'll gives you all
your thoughts probably sometimes I think
I have been fed - he's been smart you go
hey we don't have all day we all doesn't
have it's not what it's the ultimate way
it's the only way you don't have to be
smart yes but no yes to do and then it's
gonna work the only guys stick with
what's work you know it's not gonna work
you've been in Africa you know it's not
gonna work if your friends are this is
not good you never be any doubters not
gonna work no doubt that should be
eliminate you should be a doubt
Annihilator
you should be Annihilator of doubt you
kill people in the ring you should kill
doubt in your mind and then your soul
when y'all kill it it's dead fight it
every day cuz it's gonna be hard not
going anywhere
let's rise try those many negative
thoughts that you as possible you gotta
throw as many and triple the positive
thoughts whatever thought those three of
them you throw 16 back at them how much
you love yourself and how great you are
and how you love God for your hands and
your feet and your legs and your skin
and your movements everything thank you
your gratitude for your life yes you
know your blessings triple when you have
gratitude you just do be agreeable don't
you think God give him gratitude my
mother for my hands thanks my mother for
caring for me to make me put in that
situation gratitude by your mother
something nice thank you mom it's all
gratitude so I learned gratitude
gratitude I was friendly I was generous
but I always did it to get something you
know you got to do it for nothing it
comes back it's just what you do out
there coming back to you my first I was
the hater - so that's - a lot of stuff
happened to me I was hating on people
jealous for people you know in my mind
keep my thoughts
mad at him I wanted that woman you know
yes jealous no less should come back
around he just come back you can't help
it
it keeps you nice if anybody get those
[ __ ] cousin to come back boo me I
mean what happened to my man hypercar
look that [ __ ]
yes no no he was hating on you I like
the are done pitching [ __ ] [ __ ] then
like what you saying that [ __ ] you know
that [ __ ] happens you know got to keep
your thoughts clean yeah no bad [ __ ]
that was when this bad got some bad she
gets it I'm sorry I didn't mean that God
whatever that's just my thing yeah I'm
back to you anything the [ __ ] imma
great I'm firm believer
I think you're right on and with all of
that you know well Francis I know you
gotta get get out of here where you
going right now that sense when you
leave here where you going what's your
next uh going back to Vegas
fake will you don't fake it will you
live in big I live in vaguely live in
the Silverado ranch survivalist over
that were Easton which one the Henderson
Las Vegas before no no no yes Las Vegas
prove what before before Houston yes
yeah yeah [ __ ] that man it's been
awesome having you here brother
yeah good one to use thank you very much
I knees so justice sorry only how do you
handle your money are you good with
money
oh really good money I'm really good you
know like that's as I said I was I was
saying before about my mom I'm like
about about the same way you know I
always think about tomorrow about next
year I always think like this could be
the only thing that I have from now you
know how do I get a handle it you know
trying to be smart trying to think about
tomorrow next year you know why are you
doing that to live for today you know
it's always think about that they live
for that they enjoy this moment this
morning right here the second way that's
only happiness when you're in the moment
we're not in the moment right this like
it but sometimes we're talking about
this in the moment thinking about 9:00
up to this moment Neff that's happiness
yeah and it became very difficult to me
to like live in the moment as you say
because I always carry it like this fear
like oh this thing could break down no
let's keep it let's save something let's
save for nine late that doubt is never
break down it's not gonna break down
you're destined to be here for something
you doesn't help your mother you have
things to do how could it break down I
think you put that thought in your mind
it can't break down I can take the
turkey get my [ __ ] great that
don't say that again
[ __ ] yeah great I can't get my mother
[ __ ] I wanted that what I'm taking about
breaking now
think about it's gonna go well and I'm
gonna be over here and I'm gonna give a
grandkid and that's what she taught me
to take care of a grandkid
yeah you say as you said before you have
the deal they got under David and
sometimes you have this positive thought
you keep having positive thought and
sometimes the negative thought trying to
sneak around after a fire that's cool
that's cool right yeah
doesn't happen to you what don't know
what happened something else oh yeah I
mean like when you keep hyper fighters
you fight it with again this negative
thought even though you're trying to be
positive all the time but there is some
moment like I don't know like negative
trying to take over I have to really
fight hard to put him away you know well
like do they have new don't you some
negatives and the intervening your
positive thoughts absolutely how about
you how about you listen it's in
practice
you ain't doing different yeah what
choice are you gonna make you lose the
negative with it it'll take you away
from all of us probably our day with the
positives will keep us together forever
and see us succeed and prosper get
abundance we're positive yeah that's
what we're gonna stay and listen it was
easy everybody we do they can fight that
everybody can fight the temptations
that's the whole thing once you do good
cause give me a minute of hey the second
hammer so he got really likes a man let
me throw this [ __ ] is me right stab
matter than God let me throw this money
let me throw this house at him see how
you ask that
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] yeah they're sticking with the
bright side as the best the best dice -
listen yeah that's gonna happen I see
this happening your success the light is
on you that's a trip you don't even know
but you feel it the right is on you you
don't know why but the right though you
anybody you see like you honey but I see
them like come on look everybody you
seek [ __ ] on the [ __ ] you you got it
all
don't [ __ ]
and listen I've been around
oh yeah okay no one wants you to not dig
my words out nobody wants to know if
it's possible maybe if you don't know I
like you more than you like me I can get
a price from you you know that's what it
comes you always gotta let people you're
the prize you're the champ you're the
best fighter to God's creation you gotta
believe that the best fighter since the
beginning out of the Dawn's you know you
have to believe that yeah yeah I know
it's laughing but you have to believe it
you have to believe it because if you
don't believe it you won't be that
person
and you're on that road to try to be
that person so even though it's
embarrassing
why are you on this road there's role is
to be the greatest fighter in history
for the world that's what the road is
for you on the road laughing no I don't
want to know you gotta accept me I
embrace your dance you gotta embrace it
this is it greatness you're on the road
don't be afraid of it greatness is scary
that's why a lot of great people don't
make greatness because they're afraid of
it
you got a grasp this day is mine but you
know ordained by God you have to believe
it don't have to tell nobody us believe
it I know when I say these words is what
it's not cool so when I used to hear
there was a [ __ ] I know you want those
world ordained cards so damning me with
greatness and it's true but you gotta
believe it why wouldn't you wanna do it
why he gave less people than you
greatness people rather than you
greatness why wouldn't you want to give
you greatness because you ID be awesome
because you believe yeah believe it said
it believers if your way of worshiping
him believing it
yes creating you're his creation why are
you gonna be negative to something that
God made he made you why you think
you're nothing why I think negative
things about your card made you use oh
my god
if you don't like you you know I can't
didn't know now if you don't like you
yeah you got love you if you love God I
love you you know you've got a God's
creation so you to disrespect yourself
and set yourself up I was what's that
word sabotage yourself you disrespecting
her I fed the found out late in life all
I was doing with disrespect me I wasn't
disrespecting myself I'm God's creation
I'm just expecting a hammer
keep yourself clean but you gotta think
when you see when you know well I should
he saw anything you think you did it was
bad you didn't like he saw you do it
look he's looking at these maps he's
watching us so we're gonna have to
explain why I didn't know people thought
that you are a boxer I didn't know that
you're like Phyllis
I have to be beaten and submission
didn't happen it didn't happen happen
tonight I have to go to prison for this
I had to lose all my money for this and
lose my wives and lose my gold digger
girlfriend who I love so much I'd lose
all that stuff for this to get whatever
I have whatever you think I had back to
look it's all about loss and all about
gain keep my game is about lost
yes and you can you always again more
when you love something no doubt about
you appreciate it more than gratitude
life is about loss if time goes on we
lose fights you lose people we love lose
our hair then we lose our life you know
it's all the loss but by the exhaust but
from all these losses we learn so much
and all that all the experiences that we
learn it's just inconceivable it's just
beautiful life is beautiful even at its
worst at its worst it's beautiful if
they have life is beautiful even slavery
times they laughed and enjoy that moment
of life when they was treated so badly
they had a moment with here sit down
laughing they're laughing at the slave
master it's laughing in that moment yes
I'm pleased yes yeah that moment is all
about the moment nothing nothing forever
none last day if we were happy companion
sees you know me continuously like every
second of the minute we was happy we
might have a heart attack how could
nobody happy every second of the day is
this it's not enough time we have to be
other things by happy we have to be sad
we have to be there determined I have to
be you know we have to be pretty precise
on how we make our next move you know we
have to be practical amount right we
have to be so many things and then we
have to be happy if so many things have
to be encouraged it and be happy yeah
yeah to make that movement speaker
because if you're happy all the time and
you don't appreciate it
I don't way ya know that's why you have
because you understand pain and pleasure
you know me yeah it's awesome though
that's a [ __ ] great show that's the
science of love right and pleasure it's
been great having you here brother
my dope yeah no your dope because you're
doing dope because you're the future
you're special than all of us is this
your future in your prime but imagine
that the future in this crime the future
doesn't make sense we out the bus know
the past dictate doesn't dictate your
future the past is the past and the past
can't live in the future
the passive stay in the past because
when it comes in the future it
deteriorates the future
it stays in the past the future doesn't
belong in the past yes but the past Bute
the future that's what I'm saying the
plan the past the past can see the
future yes the past can't see the future
but here being involved with it if I'm
the future Chum you are the past charm
and you're you being charm in the past
buuuut me going to be charm in the
future and you mean gem in the future
it's gonna allow another champ and
Africa to be the champ yeah
it's just how it goes you always gotta
pay it forward so past beaut the future
absolutely okay awesome Mike great show
but I think you're the great show your
answers thank you more more than great
I don't my English is not good enough no
they won't have to know their words
which is beyond great but this is more
than great you're great Mel Burke you
keep doing what you do always look up
Alex believe in yourself even when times
are hard
oh it's believed don't lose doubt yeah
yeah
get away the nightly doubting every
morning I asked God to vaporize any
doubt that might linger in my mind
that's one of my affirmations I said I'm
a doubt Annihilator yeah
vaporize that [ __ ] no doubt has there's
no use to you
you know think of you all you got to say
I'm a future king of this world every
day I'm a future king and that's where
you see this toggling you see the
beautiful people in that beautiful cars
in a beautiful house and they listen I'm
a future king to this world it's all be
mines one day I mean look at me that's
what I say in every way I'm getting
better and better
that's what I thought about that like
the surf believing some time you wake up
you stand in front of your class you
look at yourself you just feel like the
king I'm like I can have these are gonna
do these are gonna do that trying to
convince yourself and that also help you
to kick out the doubt absolutely you
don't convince yourself you already know
this is gonna happen you have to let
yourself be aware of it did you want but
you let yourself people always need
affirmation even before fight I need it
because I'm a low self-esteem you gotta
do that but I'm a megalomania because I
believe I deserve everything you know I
mean well that was your affirmation I
was part of your affirmation absolutely
I refuse to lose a few lose I refuse to
lose even losing matters I refuse to be
discouraged nothing will discourage me
for reaching my goal you're a great man
you can't let them look like a little
loss discourage you great people don't
let not lost the skirt they let them
influence them yeah I lost you influence
you to be better yes lost heard YouTube
to be come to find the best version of
absolutely absolutely Mike I'm gonna
take a self
yeah out of here hey what happen - I got
it from the the PFL we've gone yeah Don
[ __ ] gone
Mike came out Donnie Davis you know Don
Davis yeah yeah Don Davis loves you me
of course he does well David letting us
know you don't have to fight with you go
over here and stop
p'mote so doing your training over there
you can still fight earlier but promote
over there and channel with him I'm
sorry
hey why not why not well he told me that
then he's not alive yeah that's what he
would do
yes I do it yes I saw him last week
anything yeah a couple of guys over the
you wanna bring over it he can get him
over here now yes hey you get your bar
over here too hey listen this is this is
what you're doing your affirmation you
touch your estimation they help you find
the right people to get involved with
your life to push your career to help
you do things you're gonna get in touch
with the right people the right people
in life is gonna help me with my life
I'm gonna connect myself with the right
people to help my mother and my friends
my life my career I have a great life in
America thank you God
yes I saw done last week at the Pierre
fair and we have we talked a lot about
like fighting and it was very
interesting about Africa and I was only
on fine fine so give me some guy this my
card called me email me the information
we're gonna take some guy and promote
them and that's money right there
buried in half insane money and that's
all you tell whoever's you're monitoring
hey let me get over these [ __ ] three
fights a little bit and you could do
where you fight you get me the promotion
I really promote your fighter training
if I do whatever was you over here and
fight of it and I'm not saying that I
love dinner is the context not what you
want after your fights here
hey we have other places to go it's just
business it's just business nothing
personal
yes it's business baby not personal well
I fancy good things happen to you you
know you deserve it definitely thank you
for coming over
it have to believe it don't go get the
scurries nice looking let's go out yeah
[ __ ] everything that's what you should
be doing as a coach in my corner yeah
you put me out not on an absolutely pump
missiles I might fit the other guys
managers I'm Connie I'm talking I'm you
oh no it's a fight that [ __ ]
really when we were fighting
[ __ ] I had my drawer the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] homo suck my
dick it's just great thanks for watching
this episode of hot box and Mike Tyson
Thank You Francis I'm Evan Britain and
I'm Mike Tyson we're friends how do we
find you oh you got me and Instagram
Twitter on you yeah my what's the name
tell these people how to get in touch
with you my Instagram mr. Francis and
y'know my cuter on my Facebook and uh
this is my man contact me how many
people you're looking at him now you
know you have a lot of people yes um
tell anybody any single people out there
that interested in talking to you yes in
a Potomac atomic weight Potomac way but
time with taller tonic platonic
relationship you tell flat for me take
out my shirt you got the price you gotta
know the price is nothing come free
everybody this African royalty here
[Music]
[Music]